there's a movement that is depending
shower routines across the country
there's a new trend in the beauty world
it's called the no poo method the secret
could be skip the shampoo your hair is
it better off without it at least that's
the slogan for the no poo movement
that's got people claiming they haven't
used conventional shampoo in years and
their hair looks amazing
but is this just a fad would really
happen if you didn't shampoo your hair
for an entire year
to find out we asked dermatologists
Angela Jhelum MD from Mount Sinai
Hospital in New York
so what shampoos do mostly is they do
what's called saponification so their
actual shampoo comes along and wraps
around oil and dirt
and when you rinse kind of comes out but
most conventional shampoos are too good
at what they do
stripping away too much oil from your
hair to the point where you start
producing extra oil to compensate as a
result after the first few days without
using shampoo your hair will look and
feel way more oily than normal
especially if you have straight hair so
for people that have straighter pattern
hair and like I said what happens with
that pattern hair is the oils the sebum
tend to progress down the hair shaft
faster so their hair is gonna feel oily
or dirty or sooner after a month of no
shampoo that oil will have caught a good
amount of dead skin cells dirt and
possibly even bacteria which could start
to make your scalp itchy and even smell
kind of funky that's that you may see
some again what you would get is
sometimes older you would get some
trapping of bacteria on your scalp after
six months to a year all that gunk can
clog up your hair follicles which can
prevent new hair from growing and over
time ultimately lead to hair thinning or
even hair loss
there's also a risk of your scalp
getting infected from all the bacterial
build-up so the signs you want to look
for that would be problematic that are
telling you you're not washing your hair
often enough our scale older sometimes
pimples that lead to they're basically
saying you're getting an infection or
bacteria those would be the signs that
you would know that you're not washing
often enough but here's the thing
rinsing your hair with gentle cleaning
agents like baking soda or even just
plain water is often enough to prevent
itching hair loss and infection so how
often should you be rinsing so to not
wash it all to use no water no co
washing no detergent shampoo I think the
cutoff for how long you can go really
does depend on your styling pattern so
many people can do that for a couple of
days some people can do it longer I
would say 2 to 4 weeks for example if
your hair is locked or if you have any
kind of prosthetic in your hair like a
weave or braid you often can go a little
bit longer just because of the way the
hair is kind of tied down and not
getting as disrupted so if you would
like to wash your hair less frequently
try to go maybe I'd say about three days
to a week and see how you do so you
should still wash and rinse but you
don't have to repeat every single day
just try it out and see how you do